Mark: Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
Mark: and welcome to "Hearts and Heroes".
Mark: Now, this is a fan-made game,
Mark: and I have not played a fan game... in a long, long time,
Mark: but I'm super happy to be able to
Mark: get back into this one...
Mark: because this one—
Mark: A lot of passion has been poured into it,
Mark: and it's been being made for a while.
Mark: And I do intend to play a lot more fan games...
and I want to stream 'em,
and I want to do a whole bunch of other stuff, but...
I just haven't had the time,
but now I do.
So we're gonna play through this full game.
and we're gonna... take our time,
and we're gonna see every little bit...
We're just gonna play, we don't need any log in here.
"Arrow keys to move, Shift to run,"
"Interact with Space or Enter,"
"Exit... with Escape,"
"Alt..."
"Command plus Alt for Fullscreen."
Okay...
Alright.
"The characters in this game"
"talk about some heavy topics."
"Discretion advised."
So, just so you know.
"This is a game for the fans, about the fans."
"Not only that, but this game is a reflection of"
"the developers and who we are."
"It's a reflection of how we learned and grew as people,"
"and the thing we love and enjoy."
The things.
"We hope you enjoy it as much as we loved making it."
Yeah.
And it you guys want to play this for yourself,
I'll put a link in the description
if you don't want anything spoiled in here...
because this game, apparently, is about you guys.
"Hello? Is anyone here?"
*sniff*
mmm
"Guess not."
"I need to find a way out of here."
All right. Okay.
"It's empty."
"Nothing to help me here."
Can I at least make my bed?
"The bed I woke up in, except that I don't remember"
"sleeping here in the first place."
"I see... nothing?"
Okay. All right then.
Does that mean you're blind, or...
do you actually not see anything?
"That's a pretty picture!"
This is a pretty stool!
This is a pretty table!
*gasp*
*creepily* Hiii
"Wait a second... this is—"
*teleportation noise*
Whoa!
"Hello there!"
That's me... that's me, guys.
"What the hell? How did you—"
"Oh my god! You're Markiplier!"
"In the flesh!"
"Well... sorta..."
"So, I know this isn't the best way to meet,"
"but I need you to come find me."
"What? Where are we?"
Oh... Come with me, come find me?
I don't know why my brain—
*not quite Tiny Box Tim's voice* "Hiya, Mark!"
Oh, god *laughs*
Ahhh
Uhh...
"Tiny Box Tiiiim! There you are, my lil' biscuit!"
"Thanks for letting meh know she was here."
"What's goin' on!?"
"Well for starters, you're dreaming right now!"
"Well, I guess that explains things."
"None of this is actually happening."
"Well not exactly... It's not just you dreaming."
"I'm dreaming too."
"All this will make more sense if you come with me."
"Where are we going?"
"A place where you'll be safe."
"Safe from what?"
"I'd really love to tell you, but"
"we really should get a move on."
"But why?"
"Just trust me okay?"
Yeah, that doesn't sound suspi— whaaaaaaaaa-'kay
Using the glowing power of my heart on my sleeve!
*teleportation noise*
*quietly* Whoa...
Cool!
Woah, feeling a little dizzy
Now can I know where I am?
This area is basically "home base" for people like us
???: Like us?
You, me, and many others,
were chosen to join the fight against the Terrorlings
???: The what?
Hear me out on this, all right?
Terrorlings are like demons that
feed off of negative emotions.
Sadness, anger, grief, and fear.
They can only affect people's dreams as of now,
but the damage they can cause is very real.
And if they grow strong enough I'm afraid their darkness will begin to seep into the waking world.
That sounds...
not good
Yeah it's definitely not good
But that's why we're here to help
This is the hub
Or as some people call it, the Markihub
And by some people, I mean literally only I call it that
Seriously?
Hey, I'm staying on brand, all right?
So what do you do here?
Well, people train for battling the terrorlings.
They also gather supplies
and meet up their teammates before missions.
Then, the third shift bell strikes,
a portal will open
to take you to the person that needs to be saved.
Alright, awfully efficient here in this dream world
*bell tolls*
Ooh no
Speaking of, there's the first bell
You've still got a lot to do, but before that, follow me to the training room
okay
uh- oh- but tiny box tim went down south!
All right fine, I guess I'll follow you
Is this the training room?
No- yes! It is. Hello
hi
oh
all right, I'll save
I saved
good, great
okay, now that we're here
let's fight!
That's how I treat all the fans that I meet
Let's fight immediately, punch me in my face!
Wait what?
oh boy
Let's do this!
Bu- wait what how do I do this?
Let me go through the basics
sh- shut- shut your face, let me, I'm talking
There are four possible choices to play.
You can attack using your weapon by selecting attack.
You can also use skills that need MP
for a more powerful attack.
If you're out of options,
you can guard yourself using the shield
or use an item to heal your party
all right
okay
I'm gonna power strike you
that's all I've got
HUUUH
*slap sounds*
I bet that hurt!
*slapping sounds*
how bout one of th- ow
why would you do that
that's so mean
oh welp nope
I— take that!
ahhhhh
oh, whumpus whump
was I..?
was that a
did you call me
what did you say?
You holding up there buddy?
I'm doing, I'm doing fine
I've got multiple bleeding contusions all over my face
Here take these:
Mark gave blululu a heart fragment and a rum and doctor pep
Oh thanks!
Open the item menu and choose the heart fragment to restore some of your HP
If you are in need of MP, you can use the rum and doctor pepper I gave ya
It's not really rum, it's actually just Dr. Pep and grenadine
we just say it's rum to look cool
and also because if I drink anything , I'll die
There are all sorts of item health items, mana items,  power-ups, and many different secret special stuff
Make sure you always have a few in your inventory in case you need 'em
No giving up now!
so shut your face and just keep hitting me
Aah!
owww
Why are you hitting me right in my dick?
How, why?
y- Got you there, didn't I?
By using this skill, I inflicted a status effect on you
Status effects are inflicted by certain skills or items and they can weaken, poison, or stun the enemy
Alternatively, they can strengthen your allies
Now that you're confused, you won't be able to focus on who you're attacking
Anybody coud get hurt
This gives me a chance to fight you off more easily
alright
HABOOM!
too late, owwwww
Hiya!
huuuu
Alright then, not too shabby
Thanks, that wasn't as bad as I thought it'd be
I kept whaling on your crotch over and over and over again
You'll get the hang of it in no time
But now that you've gotten a bit of a feel for fighting you should go ahead and choose your class
My class?
Everyone has a different fighting style
Go talk to the weapons dealer in the armory
He'll help you choose what class you wanna learn
Now I have some other things to do real quick
Come find me when you're done and I'll tell you more about the terrorlings and your mission
This can't be real!
it's all just a dream, you even said!
Oh, trust me
this dream might be a dream, but you'll dream soon enough how powerful dreams could be!
I think I made my point.
Before you go, you obviously know my name, but I haven't asked you yours.
My name is...
blu
my name is-nope..
My name is..
my name is
*thinking sounds*
t- tuu-
toooooooomp
MY NAME IS TUUMP!
Welcome aboard, TUUMP!
It's good to have you on the team
it's pronounced TOOMP!
Come find me after you're done.
all right, TUUMP away!
TUUMP is strong!
Also, what do these people do, are these people just dancing back and forth?
I can win this with my eyes closed
probably not a good idea
Nah, I'm goin- I'm going easy on you
I'll wreck your shins, mate!
Maybe if you could reach them
Oh, it's on!
All right, what are you doing?
I may be small, but that doesn't mean I'm weak
all right, ok, all right, backing off
I'm just waiting for my friend Dave so we can practice
all right
Welp!
you guys keep beating the shit out of each other I'll just carry on my way wherever the hell I'm going
ooooh
warf- uh
Warfy?
Hello?
*warfstache voice* Good evening ladies and gentlemen, player, and all other configurations of being
My name is Wilford Warfstache and this is my weapon shop!
I'm in charge of sharp objects
Ready to choose your class?
ok
The following tutorial can be skipped by holding down the shift button
There are 3 main classes:
Warrior, Defender, and Mage.
Each of these 3 have different stats, pros, and cons
There are also subclasses for each one of these
Warriors are agile and evade attacks more easily, but their attacks are lower
They have medium attack strength and defense but they have higher agility and luck
Attack: medium, Agi: high
oooooo
too many numbers
Defenders have high attack and defense points but aren't as agile as warriors
Their attack probability is lower and so their mana and HP
Inflicting states is not common
Attack: high, Defense: high, HP: high
Oookay!
Mages have medium attack strength and low agility, however they can use magic attacks which inflict status effects and heal their allies
They have high magic and defense
ok
all right
Choose your class
Remember, this decision is final
I'll go with mage
I already know what I want
I wanna twiddle around some magic around these...
*kissing sounds*
fingies
all right, let's do this
TUUMP aquired a wooden staff and mage armor
Sweet! I'm ready to destroy those Terrorlings!
Don't forget to open the menu and equip your weapons and armors
*warfstache voice* Good luck, and be sure to come back around for an upgrade next time you're around
or alternatively I could just stab you in your teeth
all right, hello, who are you?
I'm a warrior!
I'm just here to pick up a new sword
ok
I still haven't decided my class, but I need to go train with my friend
I wish this were easier
Hey! just make up your mind like I did!
Just close your eyes and just decide something at random
things usually work out after that
all right, hello
You ready?
I think so
Great! Now I'll explain things a bit more
Every person has their own Terrorlings.
In a dream, they manifest themselves into entities that are familiar to the victim
They invade the person's head and attack them, slowly scraping at their sanity
Our job is to go into their dreams and save them before the terrorlings do too much damage
*bell tolls*
BONG
There isn't much time left before the portal opens and there's just a couple more things you need to do
Sometimes I like to do a quick send-off before the shift starts
It can get tough out there
and so a few words of encouragement are always good
For now, you'll want to go stock up on supplies
Here's some Dreeeeam Points
It's a made-up currency I made
Dream points? Did you just say that trademark out loud?
uhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhh
uhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhh
nooooooooooooo
It's our form of money. I made it up, like I said. Shut up, stop asking questions!
All right, let me know when you're done
all right I- *noises from mark*
woah woah woah gimme stuff!
Uhhh, wait,  you said opposite of the training room, right?
maybe opposite as in other side ohhhhhhhh
That would make a lot more sense. Okay, who are you?
People aren't really greatful around here
I mean, I saved you. Shouldn't I get some recognition for it?
I don't know what you did, but you can shut up with that attitude there because I don't even know you
All right, this is not the...
*gasp* Google!?
What are you doing here?
Hello!
Okay, Google!
*robotically* Hello, human
What gives you the right to interrupt me while I am in the middle of planning the destruction of mankind?
Tuump: Wh- what!?
Google: Hmm, do you have a command for me?
Whose file?
Mark: Mark! Ah!
Age: sevvv---
*grumpled noise*
*offended* Height: 4ft 2!
That's!
graaaaaa Stupid!
The orientation is goo!
That doesn't even make sense!
At least my Hero ID is 69-420 I do- *laughs*
I do greatly appreciate that
all right, all right
What about TUUMP?
Check back tomorrow- woahhh ok
screw you then
pssssssssh Screw you then!
I'm trying to find a file for a friend
OF a friend, never mind
Shh! I'm reading
Okay, sorry! Geez, bitch, okay all right!
good god
It's a book that everyone has entered the hub
My name is at the last page at the bottom
Does the dream world get... wifi?
I dunno
Does it even have internet?
I'm not up for reading
Oh, okay
I love reading, so you can shut up
oooh, this looks... important
Octoda- ohohoho
Blubber! Hello child, who, like me, is a normal human!
Hello shopkeeper who is completely normal in every way!
Ohh!
Perfect!
I don't know what i'm supposed to get, but i'll get a *rolled r* rum
oooh two- ooh that's a lot... two please
heart fragment
three please
toast
none please
markihorn
all please
hot sauce
please
All right, I don't know what to- toast does, but Tuump don't need!
Tuump need none of that
Byebyeeee! Okay, who are you?
Hello? Stop moving!
probably shouldn't touch- Stop moving!
I'm preparing for my third mission, I'm so excited!
The possibility of death doesn't even occur to me!
There are always supplies here at the shop
What useful information you have, thank you. Thank you incredibly
Who are you?
Being here is such an honor
How do you know that?
Are you trapped here in this dream world?
People here can be very...
energetic for sleeping people
indeedeedoodah
all right
This is my second night here. I'm so excited!
*rapid squeaking noises*
AAAAHHHH!!!
ok bye, hope I bothered you
Who are you?
Mark said he'd help me get ready to start forming my own hub soon
I really hope he remembers
Nope!
don't even remember that
I don't even know where you are
Saving people is a lot of work!
okay
sure whatever
Woah, hey!
*high pitched* Oh hi there!
Tuump: Hey tim!
Tim: How are preperations for the first shift going?
Mark: oh my god, I'm so sorry but that's the only thing that I can do
Tuump: Pretty good, thank you!
Mark: cause I'm not gonna do the normal voice cause it's
Number 1: it hurts my voice and Number 2...
god is it annoying
Tuump: I have to be honest, this place is really surreal to me
Tim: A lot of people thi- feel that at first,
Mark: so I guess I'm going with Mickey
Tim: but I'm sure you'll like it after you get used to it
I'm kinda busy at the moment
I need to get supplies for when others get back later
Go talk to Mark and he'll help you get ready, good luck!
Tuump: Thanks, Tim! Have fun!
Mark: I'm so sorry
I was ju- *laughing*
I wish I was a better person
*laughing*
ok, anyway
Taking care of people is a lot of work
Y'all need to stop getting hurt so much
Okay, whatever you say
geez I haven't even done anything, I haven't even been hurt!
also, that's a lot of hospital beds
that doesn't seem too good
seems awfully concerning
lotta suspicious prospect
All set?
ye-yeah
I'm ready to go but I still don't exactly  where we're going to do out there
I've hit people with a stick in lacrosse, but I've never been in a fight before
You just fought me!
You fought- did I hit you too hard?!
You not remember!?
Don't worry, new recruits face the easiest enemies on their first shift
Even though everyone's dreams are different, we try to make sure no one is going in to face enemies they can't handle
Tonight your mission is to help a teenage girl whose family's been going through some tough times
It caused her to have a lot of anxiety and she feels like a burden
Here, things like anxieties take form of terrorlings
They start out small, but they can pile up over time and can do some serious harm
So I have to fight these terrorlings
Yep
Once she's rescued, the exit portal will appear to take you back to the hub
And what if I fail?
You'll be fine. I know you can do it
I've lost so many recruits I can't even remember their names or faces *fake sobbing*
Anyway, you were chosen for a reason
If you say so
Then is it about time to start?
Yeah, let's get going!
am III... I'm going with you apparen- oh!
Rabble rabble rabble! Hey! Shut up! Shut your faces!
Hey! Come on now!
Hey! Shut!!! Up!!!
good
*cough*
Now that I have your attention;
We all know why we're here
There are dark things out there threatening the well-being of good people,
-I forgot my words for a second-
but we're here to stop em
Each and every one of you
has something in your heart
that can shine through the darkness
and let you reach out to others
Some of you were saved,
others were chosen
Chosen by what?
Well to be honest
I don't even have a remotely god gosh-darned clue
okay *laughing*
I don't like that
I don't like THAT
I don't like that how predictive that be
I've been doing this for a few years now and I still haven't been able to figure it out
But that doesn't mean I'm not gonna stop fighting
Every night the darkness attacks, but our numbers continue to grow with every person we've saved
Helping people is what I'm all about
So,
I'm taking this as a chance to do just that
I want you all to know
that even though things will get rough out there
I believe in you
and I know you can do it
and if it ever gets to be too much
just know that we're all here for you
and you can always ask for help
*bell tolls*
BONG
HEY BING BONG
DO GU GO GO GET EM, GO GET EM LADS
Ok alright, one more thing for new people:
See that everyone has a heart on their sleeve?
It's the mark of a hero
Not everyone you save will have one, but if they do,
it means they'll be joining our ranks in the fight against terrorlings
Alright everyone, good luck out there
Wooo!
I'm ready, let's go!
I'm so pee-hyped!
I'm punch all the terrorlings straight- ok I right see you I outi ouoghglorfllllll
Let's go!
Hang on a second, you said each person has to be saved
had to be saved from terrorlings, right?
Yeah
Then what about me? I wasn't being attacked when you came
Well, like I said, some people are chosen
That's what happened to me too
I don't know how it works, but it's just one of those things where you get the chance to do some good and you just gotta take it
I mean, I guess
It's kind of like helping a stranger who dropped their books, right?
*deep inhale* No, but- not at all, not even remotely. In fact that reflects poorly on your brain ability
But if it helps you understand, sure
Hey man I've got enough sass on my own, I don't need
blualululuh
Well, I guess we should get going. Here goes nothing
You got this!
I'll be watching from the sidelines not doing anything!
You've got great crotch-punching abilities
believe in you
ok or I'll vanish
there I go then
oh no wait I, I'm right behind you
*creepily* Always
I'm always right behind you
ok let's go
what've we got
Ready to go? sure
*sniff in* ahhhh the fresh smell of an adventure
I can't wait!
I mean, I can wait but
I won't wait!
I won't- uh oh
mm
Mmm!
Mmhmm!
Mmhmhm!
I thought I had *burp* I thought I had more time
Alright. Slender Forest, oh no
oh no
not the Slender forest
woah
So we're in someone else's dream right now?
Yep! We should hurry and try to find them before the terrorlings do
or else they'll be ripped to shreds
and that won't be good
all right, anyway
doodleydoo *snap* uh oh
Uhh, that's probably just a cute harmless forest animal right?
Well it could be...
ooooooooor
Or something's probably watching us and waiting right here to murderlize us!
I'm kidding
Kind of...
Are you going to stick with me through the whole first shift?
Aw, sick of me already?
I'll stay with you for as long as I can, but I have to eventually get back to my own objectives
*rustling*
ooh, fun in the woods
All right. Oh!
Great, I know where we are
What, where are we?
This will certainly be an interesting first mission for you
*distant scream*
aaaaaahhhh I can scream too
Sounds like someone needs help, let's go!
oh
never mind
Okay bye!
see ya
Are those terrorlings?
Yeah. Those are just little guys, but don't let your guard down
Alright then, let's hope I DON'T DIE
That's a lovely sentiment to start this off on
Hey! Jerkwads! I'm gonna hurt you with words!
uh oh
oh, seems like they might have noticed us
*battle music* Okay!
oh hi
oh this ain't so bad
Alright then, I got some magic. I'm gonna ice blast
you
gonna power strike
wumpus wump
you
Aaah!
ohohohoho
Owww, why me?!
Why only me?
alright, you're going to hit that one, I'm gonna, I'm gonna hit this one
Haa!
oh my god
beuhh
oh, I'm sorry I'm so weak
I'm so incredibly weak
Badudah!
*victory sound*
ok alright, well I guess
guess I don't get any
experience
but whatever
alright
Sure, fine. Oooh, whoo hoo!
Nice! I could use these
Maybe. I don't know
We did it!
See?
I knew you'd be fine
*beeping*
Shit!
Crap, I gotta go
You'll be okay on your own, right?
Don't worry, I got this!
I mean, no wait! Come back!
Please!
Good to hear. I'm outie!
Shut up! Don't want to hear anymore, I'm out baby!
You'll have to find that girl who ran away. She still needs your help
What I meant to say before was that this is the Slender Forest
I think you'll have to collect all eight pages to make it through
Try to stick to the path so you don't get lost
Hopefully you won't have to deal with ol' Slendy himself
I believe in you. Good luck!
Tata!
Thanks
ok, alright, bye
Now that I'm alone, this place really gives me the creeps
Yep. Alone. In a forest
all by myself
I don't think I've every actually won the original slender game so I'm pretty sure this is going to go
horribly
horribly, yeah, let's go with horribly
mmm alrighty,  sprinting through the forest, ahh, dead
The grave says, "I said 'Kill me' as a joke, Warfstache was in the room"
*giggle*
This graves says, "Disappointed, but not Surprised"
that's funny
heh, real funny there
alright, where is these gosh darn pages
I sure wish I could see farther than in front of my nose
Uh, anybody?
Hello?
ohhhhh haha
okaaaay
wow
that's actually a surprisingly good effect
wwwww- that's not good
whaaa-
Ah!
*battle music*
hhhhhhfffffffffftbbbbbbbbbt
alright fine, that's fine
whatever, I don't care
I don't, I don't even care
I don't even care, take that
I don't even care!
fine
got another level
cause you suck and I don't
Geezums. Hey look, a page
one of eight
can't go in tent
no tent for me please
euh
this is actually surprisingly spooky
it reminds me of like all those um
all those uh...
blublababubabubebebh
all these r-rpg horror games
oooh uh oh, welp, no thank you
that's shockingly well-done
Okay page!
huhuh
I don't know why I'm on a lake, but okay
I think I missed something important back there but I, I won't come ba-ohhh RIH
*battle music*
you poopy
I don't like you
Hiya! Take some of that! Eat- eat that!
and- and how 'bout some for you
raaaa
Take some of this!
ok if I attack you now is it gonna kill you or is it just gonna like
I'm outta- woahhhhh
I got you
alright you can't beat me
Too strong!
yes
that was very fortunate
if I didn't do that that would have been extremely bad
now- woah... Do I heal?
nooo
I do not
but I can heal myself
boink
easy peasy easy peasy lemon squeeze me
and I'll save
bubdybubdybubdybuh
easy, ok
ladadaaa
just gotta find these goddamn pages
if it's anything like the original slendy
it means that if I relatively stay on the path, I should find them
eventually
but I don't know
oh god damn it damn you to hell
ahhh
yes
ohh! i got a fireball!
hell yeah
and 20 drp
woah oh I got 20 drp don't try and orp I don't want it but ok that's not good
all right well see ya slendy man
woah it's the penis tower
alright
where're we going now?
I don't even know
probably not the right way because I'm big and dumb and s- oh I found another one!
never mind I'm small and smart
that's not any better
in fact I feel worse about that one
I'm big and smart
that's the right combo
yes! okay found another one on the poop rocks
seems like there's nothing el- OOOOOOkay
alright well that's an option
ooo what do we have here?
I see a page I just don't know how to get into this
ok not this way it is a gosh darn ok alright ok here we go!
nooooooooooooooooooooooooooo I got it
ahahahahahhahahahha
uhoh
hero power? I got none
fireball! uhhh
fireball! bahhhhh!
fireball!
ow
again, ow, stop
fireball
what that didn't even
MMMMMMMMMM
yeah
aaaaaaaaaall righty
we did that all right beat ya oooo that's not good
hang on I gotta slendy wait
wait a second slendy I gotta
I'm a spastic saver everyone knows this about me but I gotta do a
heeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeal
there we go. what does that even whaa
why is that there?
is that good or bad? it looks good
looks real good
alright whatever you say
is there something over here?
in this mausoleum-esk thig?
no?
welp, that's all that's in here, I don't even need to be in a gravey- woahhhh hey
how's it going
I don't think there's any ooooah
OOOO
ahh
I've only got 2 left that I need to get so
it must
beeeee
not there
i've gotten that one
so it must be
on this path here
cars yes!
one more!
yes, one more, one more, one more
I'm almost there
I did it, I'm doing it
this is oddly stressful, this is a faithful recreation *gasp*
no
let's go there
I don't need that nope
MMMMMMM
alright I think I've already gone this way haven't I?
haven't I?
have i?
ohhhh yeah I have haven't I
but I didn't get one. hold on this *gasp* yessssss. I got it! it's a dick butt
I didn't even get to look at it very much
it was just a tantalizing flash of a dick and a butt
ok well I'm out of here baby!
I'm out of here!
see ya!
fare thee well!
I guess
nothing else is gonna happen
what was with that weird rock
can this lead to that weird rock because I want to see what that weird rock was all about
if I'm supposed to be selecting everything around here
you gotta show me what that weird rock was all about
no not here. was it below this?
tittysprinkles!
I missed it!
awww cock my ass!
well that's grumpilicious
ok well I guess I'm not seeing it then
dammit
alright, I'm outie baby!
I got all the pages
and Im good to go
why do they just explode into piles of ash
also where did that girl go?!
ehh whatever it's too late- oh no
uh oh
I guess there's no going back now
wait
but what about that
what about the
well what about the
but what about
what about the g-
hey tuump
oh hi Tim, what are you doing out here?
I'm just here to warn you about the area you're about to enter
it's gonna be a bit harder than the forest so I hope you're ready
thank you Tim
also take this key
Tiny Box Tim gave you a key
you'll need it to get into the mansion
thanks!
good luck tuuuump
All right, thank you...
but what about the—
Oh— *in-game scream*
Ohhhhhhhhhhh
She's up heeere.
Got it, okay.
"Sounds like she's in trouble! I gotta find her!"
Hey! You! Assholes!
Get ready to taste my fists of fury!
All right, I guess...
Maybe, if this is actually going to work—
Hiyaaa—
Ow...
OWWW
Owie!
Hiyaaah—
Okay, well, that doesn't do nearly enough...
Welp I— I am in... trouble.
call for help
yeah i'll do that
hey, whaaaaaaaa yes!
I should have been sounding the markihorn from immediately right away that's not a sentence but I yesssssss
take thaaaaat
get shreked
I shoulda, I knew I shoulda bought all the markihorns
that's the only thing I'd ever need
all right whatever I got, I got leveled up so it's
it's all good
I think leveling up means that I don't have to- woah
this is the creepiest book I've ever seen
and I don't read
more of those pages
it won't open, it's blocked from the other side
maybe that's the way that I'm going to be coming out
ma- ohhhh hi
I'm gonna sound, I'm gonna pound the markihorn
you ain't gonna know what's gonna hit ya
sound the alarm!
boom boom boom!
oh shit!
noo
yep
it's too late for you
alright nice I could use these
when am I going to get another teammate that can help me along here
I don't recognize anything on this map
more of those pages
and a lot of bloodstains
I don't like it
oh, what is that?
is someone cleaning?
actually all the food looks old and gross
mmm food
guess I found the pantry
oh wait I read that in reverse order oop
does slender drink?
is this all here for show?
maybe not
a book
I don't wanna know what it says
ok I guess you really don't read then
who cares what the very important-looking book says in the middle of the very important-looking room
guhhhh
well hello
*battle music*
*mark imitating battle music*
I'll save my markihorn, just in case
pffft well
I think I just, I think I just realized my first problem
I wasn't, I d-, nothing was equipped
I am an idiot
but we all knew this
does my hand gesture make it better for you
I am an idiot
wooden staff, yeah, that'll be great
shield, arm shield? why not
ok
headgear, hat?
love me a hat
mi'lady
body armor
sure
accessory
great
man
if only I had been a better human being
that's something I say to myself
every single day
okay what have we got here
another book, it's a horror story, surprise, surprise
what, you read now?
huh?you judging that book by its cover?
hmm, I don't like you
why cant I take it with me? I would like that
I would like it very much
why are there so many papers in here?
It's almost as if someone was trying to make it look messy
hmm
more papers
yup mm sure is messy alright
oh no
there's a wig and a fake mustache in here.
that's not right
its a letter addressed to Slender asking for an interview
ohhhhhh! I KNOW WHERE WE ARE!
So how bout it? the interview of a life time signed Wilford Warfstache
oh is it?
oh is it really
oh, I think I understand now
wuh oh
I don't like that bear
you touch the teddy
A soft melody starts playing
*soft melody plays*
okay! Glad that happened, glad I did that!
I just got a flashback to like witch's house when the bear like just
BRMBRMBRM
I'm not sure I wanna know whats in these bottles
I'm not sure I wanna know what's in your head
okay
alright
I suppose all of this is in your head
hmm, what's this?
the melody is broken
I wonder what it means
Woop
Okayy
Alright!
"Achievement unlocked!"
DUN
DUUUHHH
Okay? *giggles*
Nice (x3)
Very nice... Very, very nice.
"More of these papers?"
I can't believe it.
I cant believe...
It's— uh oh
Uh oh
"Put it back together."
"I guess it's a puzzle. Hmmm"
*music plays again*
Ahh!
*music continues*
I got it! okay so I just need to go listen to the song and then..
put all the pieces back together
*music plays*
ok
*same music plays again*
*lock clicks open*
HEYYY
There we go!
*gibberish start of a sentence, cut off by ingame static*
I'ma charge *voice cracks* straight id— in...
'cause I'm a brave boy!
Oh, hello...
Ooh
"Come now, we all know that—"
d'uh-ooh
I... didn' t... read it, cause—
*apologetic stuttering*
I'm sorry!
"Come now,"
"We all know that you'd never be able to get rid of us."
"Aw, you scared?"
"What'cha gonna do? Cry about i—"
I like that guy's face—
*slightly goofier voice*
"What'cha gonna do? Uh, cry about it?"
Eh— "I'm... I'm not..."
"All you do is weigh people down."
"You can't do anything."
"You're pathetic, that's what you are."
*??? collapses*
Oh
Huhu
Ooh
"HEY!"
I've got a Markihorn, toot a-toot a-fuck you!
"Get over here..."
"you buncha no-good FREAKS!"
"Oh look, a new half-ass hero."
"Why don't you run away, little girl?"
"No one wants you here."
"Funny..."
"I was just about to say the same, thing, for you!"
OH SHIT here comes the Markihorn!
toodely toot ta toot ta toot GRRRRRRR
Good thing I saved this thing.
BONK
WONK
STONK
and SHRONK
Easy, peasy.
Get-the-eff-out easy.
Get outta here. (x2)
Tuump ain't gon' mess with nobody...
Nobody!
"It's alright."
"They're gone."
"Still, we should get out of here."
"Can you stand?"
"I think so."
"Great."
"Yeah, I don't like it here."
Alright.
Well, this is your big purple chair?
Hmm, what's this?
"Slender's diary?"
"Nope, nope nope! I'm out, bye!"
Wha— whaa— what could Slender's diary be about...
that's not...
good, and... wholesome, and awesome?
"I don't know why he has this."
A lasso?
Why does he have a lasso?
Eugh
Alright.
"Looks like a map of the forest outside."
Well, that would've been helpful—
Oh, it's blocked.
"This must be what's blocking the door."
Can I... un-block it?
D'okay, no I cannot.
Alright, well... see ya.
Let's skedaddle on outta here.
doodly doot de doot de doo
Ahh...
*whispers* looks like it's locked.
Okay...
Well, see ya.
See ya...
See ya, guys!
What's over here?
Anything? No, I already been in here.
Alright. Well, I'm only assuming that this is um...
Slendy's mansion...
or Markiplier Manor, for that matter...
buuut I'm not 100% sure about that;
I think it's Slendy's mansion...
which was an ooold game.
*whispers* long time ago.
"Now that we're not fearing for our lives,"
"I think I should introduce myself."
"I'm Tuump."
"Oh, my name is..."
Nope
Nope, nope, nope
Your name is...
*deep inhale*
Buuhhhh...
Beee—
Byoooooh—
You're...
Bluuuuhhr
Bluh— Blerm...
*laughing* Blermf.
Blermf!
...Blermf!
"Nice to meet you, BLERMF!"
I'm TUUMP!
"I know there's a lot to take in."
"I'm still kinda mind blown by it all myself."
"Once we get back—"
Okay...
Alright.
"Is something wrong?"
"I'm still scared. I'm sorry!"
"Why? There's nothing to be sorry about."
"You were just being attacked by monsters."
"I'd be more concerned if you weren't afraid."
"I just—"
"I'm always scared!"
"All I did was cower while you fought off those things!"
"So?"
"That's what I came here to do!"
That's how I work,
that's how I roll.
"I'm so weak and useless. I'm sorry."
"Not joining in on the fight doesn't make you useless."
"You shouldn't have to fight them at all."
"But—"
"But nothing."
"Needing help doesn't make you weak."
"It just makes you human."
"I guess you're right. Thanks..."
"No problem!"
"Come on, let's get going."
"Something doesn't feel right—"
mmmmm okay, alright
What doesn't feel right?
What is it?
Oh, why am I going back in here?
I don't like this...
*sudden noise*
wuh—
"Is that--?!"
uaahhh, ooohh
"We gotta run! Take my hand!"
Ooh, we have to find the portal.
Okay, alright then.
H-oh, hi.
Es'cuse me, sorry. Didn't mean it.
nyaaannnd, ha-wooompf
w-aaah, I was a little off, I was a little off, okay.
I don't know where this portal could be
"Tuump! You did it! I knew you could—"
"GET IN THE PORTAL!"
"Woah! Why are we screaming?"
"JUST DO IIIIAAAA"
Okay, alright then—
Uh oh
"Aaahh!"
Oh, that's not good.
uh
"Alright, let's get this over wi—"
That HP bar is...
whooof
HOOOOF
Oh mah goodnass
Take, some of... this?
Crazy foot thing?
"How the fuck do you do tha—" *laughing*
"How the fug do you do that?"
I dunno, you know what?
Honestly, I just don' know.
Here, have a crazy foot thing.
Hiyah
Take that—
That is... that is a lot of health...
b'eh, guess he's not that powerful.
Alright, I'ma freeze you~
Take some fire and ice challenge!
No? Alright, fine then.
Hero power? Nope, okay.
atttaaaacck
Wait, what just happened?
No...
Magic— I said ice blast!
Alright.
attaa— *giggles*
Hero— hero power?
Ah, Mark's manly screeches.
That... that doesn', that dun'—
*Markimumbles*
paahh
piiyoow
Ow, why only Tuump?
Why not hit the big dufus known as Markiplier?
*music is temporarily amplified*
*disturbed by music glitch*
Why was that that way? *nervous laugh*
Alright...
Whumpus... you gon' get wumped.
I know ex— *giggles*
We are literally just...
aiming straight for your crotch, and...
Slendy I don't know if you have a crotch, or, uh...
anything down there,
and I don't care, I'm not asking...
but um...
We're just taking our— We're just hedging our bets,
we're just going for the best option here...
and that seems like the most, m...
positive outcome, alternative that we could possibly d—
BOOM!
Thankfully, I got out of that awkward conversation... by...
killing *giggling* the other person in the conversation.
There we go—
"Hah! Take some of that!"
"Woohoo!"
"Oooh, shiny!"
Alright.
"Now's our chance!"
"Let's go!"
Now that he's a pile of dust,
and extremely dead,
we can get outta here!
hawoosh~
Okay, well...
"Achievement unlocked!"
"Arrival..."
*quietly* One star?
*still quietly* Nice!
*alarm beeping*
Uh oh...
Oh...
I'm alive!
H-I'm alive!
Alrighty then...
...Am I alive?
"YAWN"
"That was [a] really weird dream."
"I wish I could remember it..."
*sighs*
"I've gotta get ready, or I'll be late for school."
Okay...
"I can get back to watching videos"
"once I'm done with school."
"I really need to rearrange these notes"
"once I get back from school."
"I'm ready to go!"
Oh... kay?
How are you jumping out of bed and ready to go?
"I'll have time to write in my journal later."
Who's a good doggy?
"Hello Steve! Who's a good boy!"
uh bow woof
woof bow
bow a pet named Steve, that's funny, bow wow woof
Get outta my way, I gotta look at myself.
Lookin' good~
Tuump, you ain't never—
TUUUUMP
You ain't never looked so good.
I'm real proud of you TUUUMP
Man, don't you just—
"Ready to start the day?"
You... know it... bitch...
Yes!
"Let's go!"
Alright.
You... know it...
betch...
"Later that night—"
Okay, alright then.
"I couldn't focus in any of my classes today."
"I guess I'm still shaken up from last night's dream—"
Well, you were... so peppy this morning!
And why you go to school,
like, the moment you wake up,
'til the moment you get to bed is... just...
a buncha—WHOA
a bunch of school...
"I really love Mondays."
"I know that's kinda weird to say,"
"but it's always like a new start."
"I had German today, and that's like"
"my favorite class right now."
"And Mondays are when Markiplier posts RY... C."
"Well, he's... *cough* supposed to."
"So yeah, Mondays are..."
*clears throat*
*inhales*
*slurs* "usually th-besh deys—"
*inaudible*
"But for some reason, today was different."
"I couldn't focus, and I didn't get anything done."
"I kept dream— uh, thinking about that dream... I had."
"It was so weird and a ton of stuff happened,"
"but I can't remember any of it."
"Usually, that's how dreams go, but like..."
"I can't shake the feeling that there's something"
"I should be... remembering..."
"I know is... is that is what it was—"
"really dark at one point, then there was a burst of light"
"and that's it."
"Pissed me off that I will probably never remember,"
"but whatever."
Okay!
"Anyway, gotta see Connor tomorrow."
"He's visiting the states for two months this time."
"It'll be really cool to have him around,"
"after he moved to the UK."
"A bunch of us went after school for ice cream today, th—"
"so that was fun."
"At least my Monday ended well,"
"even though it was still distracted by that dream."
"Well, I guess that's all for my Monday."
"It's almost 11pm, so I should get going to"
BEH-EH-EH-EHD
Alright, well...
Uh, Steve!
"Goodnight, Steve! My good pup!"
Woof, bow
Bow, woof
Woof, wah-vow
"Aw, I forgot to sort these out... do it tomorrow"
"Too late for YouTube...?"
*T R I G G E R E D*
Excuse you?!
ExCUse yoU??!!
You telling me people aren't slaving their life away, 24/7
the INSTANT that they hit the Subscribe button...
There is a debt!
A blood, debt, to pay!
When you hit that Subscribe button,
that means you watch EVERY video... ALL DAY!
*quietly threatening*
and you'd better not be tired about it.
Lookin' good still, even late at night!
I like it— "Nice plant."
Alright, welp...
Exciting.
"I'm so tired."
*tired Markimoo noises*
"Sleep?" Sure.
Time for bed~
Hoop-dee doop-dee, off to dreamworld I go~
*mouth sounds*
Okay.
Get me back to fighting those goddamn Terrorlings.
I'm ready to get blood on my hands.
I'm just a— every, night, I'm just a bloodthirsty monster.
Maybe that's the twist end of this game.
*teleportation noise*
Maybe we're... the real monsters.
"Wait, where am I?"
"Welcome back! You did fantastically yesterday."
"Wait... I remember everything now!"
"How could I forget all that?"
"That's normal. It's still a dream."
"People hardly ever remember dreams,"
"and even when they do, it's vague and fleeting."
"I guess I have to apologize for not believing you last night."
"Don't worry about it."
I've only written it down so I can remember
how much you screwed me over...
but don't worry about it, don't worry about it.
"This is super unreal for me."
"But I'll take the chance I have"
"to help as many people as possible."
"That's the spirit!"
That's literally the spirit, 'cause we're all... ghosts.
*bell tolls*
Uh oh, first bong.
"Guess I'd better hurry, huh?"
"Seems like it."
"I'll be in the Training Centre if you need me."
"Come talk to me after you're"
"done with your preparations."
"You'll need to update your class"
"and get a better weapon."
h-ohh kaaay
See ya, I don't know where to get weapons—
WADE?
Wait a minute.
WADE a minute!
"Oh my gosh! Hi, Wade! What are you doing here?"
"Uh, oh, hi!"
"I'm here to help out Mark on his mission tonight."
"Really? That's awesome! Are you here often?"
"Depends. Sometimes I like a change of pace,"
"and to hang out with Mark."
"Uh, I mean— not Mark."
"Puh, that guy's the worst."
"I heard that!"
Oh, I heard that, very slow talking—
and also me making fun of you,
in a game where you're appearing
and you can't defend yourself
because you're not here... actually...
ahh-I heard that!
You're on thin ice, mister!
Alright.
"Saving people is exhausting."
True... that.
"I feel sick."
Okay...
"Hey Jude!"
"Hey guys!"
"Jude, why did you just show up?"
"Isn't it like, 5am where you are?"
"Well, I just got sleep 'cause I was playing Until Dawn."
*Badum tss~*
Oh, I hate...
that...
"You don't even have that game."
"And where are you getting your own sound effects?"
"I have my sources~"
"Where did you get those sunglasses!?"
"How are you doing that!?"
"Jude, this is why we're friends."
Alright, sorry to intrude on your conversation.
"Lani's in the File room, looking for my file."
"You should check yours too!"
Okay.
"Earlier, I told Mark I'd arm wrestle him,"
"but he probably—"
Oh, that's mysterious.
I can't read the rest of this sentence.
Eh-it's so weird.
I— I just can't— It's just... jumbled.
I don't even understand it.
That's so bizarre.
Oh well, guess we'll never know...
HMMMMM
"Good evening, young lady!"
"Would you care for a stabby object?"
Um...
"Sure, why not!" *chuckles*
Okay!
"The following tutorial can be skipped"
"by holding down the Shift button."
"Welcome back Nage..."
"Mage!"
"Before you continue,"
"you need to choose your tier two subclass."
"Mages can either choose..."
"Arcane Mage, or Nature Mage."
"Arcane Mages use powerful eh-arcane magic"
"to fight their enemies."
"Their attack is higher"
"and can heal enemies [allies] in battle."
"The only disadvantage is that"
"they don't inflict many status effects."
"Attack: medium..."
Alright, "Nature Mages..."
"...attacks are not as powerful,"
"but they inflict status effects for strategic advantage."
Oooo...
I like that.
Ahh-I like that a lot.
Mmm
I could just be straight up whammy-bammy,
or I could be all strategery,
and thinkle-thunkle about it real hard.
I'ma be the thinkle-thunkley type.
"TU-UUMP acquired an Arbor Staff"
"and Nature Mage armor!"
"Good luck! And be sure to come back around"
"for an upgrade..."
"the next time you're around!"
Okay, thank you!
Uh oh...
Hello, hi?
"Hey, there you are!"
"W-what?"
"This is really real?"
"Yeah, it's crazy, I know. I'm... still in shock myself."
Can't you see... by my shocked expression?
"But, now you'll be helping save people,"
"just like I helped you!"
You're permanently enslaved
to this dream world of helping people...
No matter what!
You won't have a normal dream ever again!
Ha ha ha ha~
"Me? I can't... I couldn't!"
"I don't want to... hold you back."
"Nonsense! We'll be an awesome team!"
I've decided this.
"You think so?"
I know so, Blermf...
I know so.
"First off, you should pick your class."
"I'm gonna go stock up on items and all that stuff."
"Will do. I'll wait for you here."
Okay, alright.
"I'm a soldier—"
Okay, never mind.
You're saying the same thing, aren't you?
"Last mission went well!"
Alright.
D-oh 'kay, uh-right!
*gibberish*
Okay!
Alright, you two still fighting?
Same people?
"No, you swing first!"
Uh, okay
"You swing first!"
Okay
"Mannequin is our friend. Don't hurt it."
Eugh
He's just gonna make out with that mannequin like a...
weirdo?
Ooh...
Ah, it worked.
"Phew! That was close."
"What the hell was with all of those spikes?"
"Now I just have to get back"
I don't trust it... not a—
WHAEH
WHOA COME ON, I barely waaaah-kay
Ah-oooh, two of 'em, that's not right
I don't like that
Hair floof? That's not right
Rebecca's Wrath? Rebecca?
"Bash the enemy over the head with Mark's"
"beloved diamond play button, Rebecca."
I totally forgot that I called...
my diamond play button Rebecca.
I didn't even know...
I didn't even know that!
Terrified flailing?
Ooooh... I li— I like to play the odds!
Hah— Okay, well the odds were not in my favor.
Let's try it again.
*war cry*
Ahhh, that's nice, that's real nice right there
Ow, that didn't hurt at all.
Why didn't I just beat the shit out of these guys anyway?
Well, this seems too easy.
I'll try it aga- *war cry*
Dammit
Alright *war cry*
There we go.
Ah, good old LordMinion777 hit
Oh yeah, oh yeah, oh yeah. Take some of that, oh yeah
Alright.  "Time to find the others."
"And I just left those kids on their own while I ran away"
*quiet, jumbled static in the background*
"Yeah yeah, I know..."
*disturbed frown*
"No, stop. It's okay."
"I left them to lead the monsters away, it's fine."
*more disturbed frown*
What was that all about?
"For easier navigation,"
"the party is restricted to only showing"
"Tuuuuump's sprite."
What?
Oh, 'cause there'd be four, ohhh, that makes sense. Okay, save
Now listen up, whatever your name is,
you better actually help in battle
and if you don't, I'll be extr-eme-ly pissed
Like, unbelievably pissed off. I will be so incredibly pissed off
So don't even try it
Okay, and we're off. Here we go, where we goin', hello? Hellooo?
Uh-oh. Welp, here we go.
Yay, we did it! Alright. At least when we level up, we're leveling up so much, that it's like-
What the fff no, no, no, I just bbbahh
Yay, we did it, alright
Ugh, okay
We got this
Whaa, I don't know what it- God, I keep skipping so much stuff!
It's not intentional
Well, that's a dead-end. I'm sure glad that I went down this way
OH BOI
*deep sigh*
It's just gonna be like Vanish all over again. It's just gonna be a non-st-
Buh-BlEHHH
What was that
"There's hallucinogenic gas in this game, remember?"
"Just remember, it isn't real."
Just like all of this isn't real, 'cause we're in a dream!
(way to break the fourth wall, Mark)
We're in a dream world, it's all a dream.
It's all just a *kissy noises* dream
Such a sweet, sweet dream
Don't even worry about it
Don't even try to worry about it
I'm gonna save because I'm worried about it.
(I think that's called a "contradictory statement" Mark)
Okay, I also gotta up my stats to get everyone
all topped off, and—
Nah, everyone's good, nah, everyone's good.
Oh, everyone is good to go.
And I'm really hoping that there's going to be some... kind of an... exit... here...
Somewhere-
Please don't be a dead-end. Not after all this ti—
uhAHahhh, scawey
Oh, it's gonna be three in a row, isn't it
Oh bOi
Here we GooOOo
Oh, they're gone, OOooh
Okay, alright, they're gone. That's good for me. Okay, alright
Oooh, hello
Who's hummin' over there?
Who's being a big ol' fart head? (Fart head?)
Oh, not this way. I don't believe that for even a remote second (You show them)
You're not going to fool me because don't l- uh-oh
(Dat face doe)
Ah, it's fine. I knew you were a sack of shit
I knew you were just a lying sack of shit that didn't actually know what you were talkin' about
Don't even try to fool me (okey)
Cause only I can fool me
I'm never fooled
Not once
Not twice
Don't. Fool me.
(Again, dat face doe)
Follow the, pip-ehs...
Alright, sure
I don't see no... pipes
Uh-oh
"Maybe we should find Mark first... He might get lost"
Oh, okay, so Mark's up this way then. Oh, okay, alright. Sure
Way to be a spoily-spoilerson
Oh, hello (hi)
The boiler room?
Hey, glow sticks!
Okay *weird voice*
Oh, hi! Hello. (hey, it Mark)
Here we go. Here we go—
esh ed-bleh-AHeh ayehh—
DOOOOOOEEEEEAHHHHOOOEEE PFP
PFP
DOOOOOOOP (don't do drugs kids)
Alright, its— everybody say hi to Doop
Like the assholes that we are
So I'm just going to assume that it's over this way
I'm not even going to bother anything because it didn't let me go this way before so I'm just gonna assume that it's over this way
Because the game was all *mocking voice*
So I can only assume that it's actually this way
And if it's not this way- ahhhh
Nooo...
Please don't be a big old bag of ass
That's ahHHH nOO
Then why did it eeeohhh
Why did it even say uGGHHH
Why did the game suuuhhhh
Fine
It's fine (exactly). Whatever
No one cares
It's all good
Because it's this way
Hello
Ah, hello, welcome
Ah, wait, I got a new ability, didn't I
Landslide
Down you go indeed. Everybody go-a down-a here-a
And you're gonna get some of Rebecca's wrath
Take that, asshole!
Ah
Ohh
Don't roll me mulls (I have no idea what he just said tbh)
These guys aren't that- woOAH
That was all?
That didn't do any- that didn't- ah
Well  this is weird
Oh, uh-oh, there goes Flamp. Flamp no!
Oh nooo
Oh no
I'm not worried about it
Nice, we did it
And we leveled up
Nah, we leveled up
Yeah, that's good
No more knocked out for you
No more life for those moles
No one need em anyway
Who needs em? No one
Ab— ahhh, oooo
A hole—
oh...
"You touch the crystal."
"Huh?"
AAAAUUUHHHH
"You learned Yandere Snap."
Sweet. Excellent.
Man, I really wish I had touched the first crystal—
I knew it! Ah, I just— I had to run, you know, I had to run
Cause I was being MURDERED by Slendypoo
So you know there wasn't really much of an option
Alright, what do we got here
Ah, that, this? I don't know if I should trust both of these
Ah, hello
Oh, had to think about that one, didn't cha
Oh, where are we now
This is it, the key should be in here somewhere
Great now we can find our way out of here
Looks like we're gonna have to get around those creeps to get the keys
If we're quiet, i think we can avoid them
Or
We fight em?
We could fight em?
Where do you wanna throw a glowstick?
um
douu
South?
That didn't help nothin', did it
That didn't help nothin'
Ohh, oww
What the hell
*screech RIP headphone users*
Yeah, that was pretty stupid, wasn't it
Pretty stupid
Whatever, it wasn't that stupid
You're stupid, and I'm not stupid because I know what I'm doin'
Not really, anyway, but, I think, I THINK I know what I'm doing
Alright, we got this
Let's do this
Let's do it to the WEST
ah, what was that?
Okay, what's this tub of waaater
I'm real sneaky-like
Really sneaky
Aaaa haa
Way to suck dong.
Now what've you got for me?
What are you gonna do, huh?
Where do you wanna throw-
Oooh close left or far left?
Let's do far left
That's right, get outta here
Ooh way to suck
Uh oh
Um...
North
huh what was- OW
Welp
That sucks
Oh, I didn't save either
Oahhh, c**k
The answer must be close left, right?
oh
Aaaah
Alright, let's go north
There we go baby
And also lemme save
I should've saved before that, but that's okay
Man, we got a dream team here
Tuump
Blermf
Flampt
Dooooooop
..and Mark
Ah, beautiful
Alright lets skeda-
uh oh
But I just saved
Oh, northWEST, I didn't even see that as an option
Well, that would've been good to know a long time ago
I was right. I was very close to the correct
Alright, I'm just gonna be real far away. You'll never know
Run
Run!
That's right, you can't get to me. There's a mysterious pipe in the way!
You suck, I'm the best
Alright
I'm just going to save anticipatorially
Yes, that's a word (sure)
I know what I'm talking about
Alright, here we go
Uh oh, pipe
Well that's not good
Well I just gotta do this mano e mano style don't I
Oh, now it's a fight. I could've fought em before. It would've been fine
Alright, we did it. We're the best
Hydrohelix? That sounds awesome
Alright
Got more Dr. P
I don't know what that means, but we got it
Jeez you almost got us killed
I did?
Yeah you just flinging knives everywhere, you almost hit Blermf
What no I didn't Blermf did I
I uh
Woah woah chill out, the both of you
Fighting isn't gonna solve anything
lets just focus on getting out and we can talk about this later
I don't have time for this. I'm Dooop
Obviously the main character here, you shut up
Ya'll shut up!
Alright, I guess we're leaving then
I suppose, thanks for making me not do all that again
That's awfully handy
But we didn't get the key, so what was the point of all that?
Honestly, who knows
Stuck here doing bullsh*t
Also I should prou-
Actually, no. I don't want to do that
I was gonna increase M-mar-ks- mp, but i decided it was a stupid idea
Hydrohelix?
Drown b*tch
Idek what that's gonna do, but it sounds awesome
So let's do that
Hiyah
I wanna see em drown, just drown
no nah nah
I wanna see em drown
Okay, that didn't...
That wasn't even worth it
That didn't even do-
I could've done the multi-targeting ability, and I would've gotten a lot more than that
Even fireball 2 is better that that one
Maybe they have a chance of dying. Maybe that's the deal
Idek anymore
There you go, knocked out did ya. No health for you, do ya
And get wumped one more time and then you're on into the afterlife
Easy, easy, easy, easy
Got it, levels out the wazoo
Ah sweet
So, there's gotta be- woah
God, everytime- everytime
I accidentally skip something
I'm sorry
Oh no
Dooooop
Why would you go
Why would you go on your own?
Why why would you do that dooop
You're not strong enough. You're a big wimpy baby
Why would you do that
Alright whatever Doop
Do you even have any equipment
No, you don't, Dooooooop
He's a big, dooooooopin idiot
Don't look back
Idk about that, seems to be-
I got a good feeling about this one. This is definitely gonna be- nooopppeee
F**ckin a**hole
Someday I'll get outta here
Someday, and the breathies will all shut up
but someday I'll get outta here
Some-
Augh g*d*amm*t
Uh oh
or dont
Not show yourself is also a very good option
shut up you stupid voices in my head
shut up
you stupid
and ugly
and I'm hhhhooot
You're gonna shut up
Alright okay alright
I dunno what I don't care about
but I doNT
That's for samn su-wo oah
(its an Irish accent, who knows why)
uh oh
Oh we're literally gonna take down the gate
Aaah I see how this do
Do I actually need to take care of everybody
Or is this gonna happen by itself
I'm gonna assume I need to his everybody because. that doesn't seem right
Backstab
Heh this gates gonna bleed
Bleed gate!
Oh, nevermind it didn't work
Shockingly
Uh oh, welp
This is going poorly um
Lets try full heart
doink
And then you backstab that Gate
And lets backstab these guys
Seems to be a problem
Ooow
Whyyy
Why is the Gate hitting us that doesn't even make any sense
Why would the Gate be hitting us?
Alright let's foucus our attacks on one of these guys
Woah what a crit baby
What a crit baby
Alright wait no you're gonna use your magic on that guy
And then youre gonna use the item on Tuump
there we go
Faboski, ah no crit
Aah come on please?
hiyaah
Oh sorry
Sorry theres two of them
Hiyaaah
There you go
Oh no the Gate stood there
Menacingly
Menacinglyyy
Alright lets see, alright lets go for it
Ah, well this is gonna take a while
Oh come on
Alright we're gonna use, we're gonna go for it
We're gonna go for the Ultra Ball
I don't know what this is gonna do but I'm gonna do it
And you're gonna do one of, you're gonna do a
Marhor- Pound the horn!
Wow
I shoulda done two ultra balls
Da**it it wasn't enough
G*d*mm*t
I'm right here
Yeah it was absolutely unnecessary
But I like overkill
So alright
Get out of my way
Fff*ck yeah
I'll be takin that, scuse me
And away we go
Blinded, by the light
Ahuuu we're gonna go get taken care of by a booox
A very smart box
Way to go Tim
Welp, glad we got no progress made
Perfect
Ah, oh wakey wakey my eggs and bakey
or the universe
Whatever, starting to lose it out here
Its a human leg
Steve please
Oh wait nevermind alright
So why would
So why would people continually spend time in this dream
If it's just draining them in real life
That seems bad and counterintuitive and problematic
I dunno, seems bad, I dunno
Better head to school then, alright I guess we're outta here again
Uh because I'm a genius
I dunno something about this dream world just seems wrong and off
I don't like it
Like it's
It's kind of asking a lot of people, you know what I mean
It's kind of asking a lot of people
If it's draining them in the real world
I'm sure there's some lesson to be learned about that
Aaauuugh
iiiiIIIII keep doing it
Seems like a goodbye so my instinct is to sprint away
as fast as I can
Whatever you said, I'm sure I listened to it and it was real important
I said that before I read it.. okay
Alright see ya, see ya
You take care of yourselves
Ding don bing bong
Oh that was it okay alright then
It's just me and Flampt apparently
Okay what do you have?
Ooh this seems
Buai I'm not gonna waste my valuable derp
I'm not gonna waste me valuable derp on any- wait what if I sell?
oh wait what id I se- Can I sell something?
No?
Sh*t
Oh this, yes please
Got it nailed it, outta here
Oh, probably something I could equip
But something tells me equipment isn't as important as this game suggests it might be
Alright whose here? Hello?
Oh I read that backwards I'm sorry
I didn't know any better, I don't know anything any better anyway
Aww
I'm sure its not
No shutup
I'm not ready I'm still exploring around
Can't wait to stab all those demons in the baaack
That's sad
okay
Hm
There is some kind of dark underbelly in this isn't there
No probably not
Hello
I dunno
And that was terrible I'm gonna forget you said that
Boblem
Alright um, do you have any-
Eggnog?
Pretty good, but I don't really care about that
Oooh nope nothing else right its just, its all ultra ball all day
All of em, that's all I'm gonna get I don't really care about anything else
Water?
Baah no i don't care about it
Nope nah its all good I'm outta here baby
I'm outta here sorry just outta here I got everything i needed
Hey Googs!
Hey googsie moogsie
Reading cant solve all your problems okay
Alright, mkay
1854 that's, pretty low
Why does everyone have an orientation slot?
That is- that is confusing to me
Oh I see okay, I knew that already
Uuh I think we're all ready to go right?
Nothing else right?
Alright
Here we go
Ah, alright
Hm, well lets get some squeaks for good luck
That's good, and lets save for good luck
Cause that's the really important thing that can give you good luck
And away we gooo
I'm ready, are you ready?
You better be ready, if youre not ready then youre surprisingly unready
Aaah Amnesia
Alright fine, I guess you just don't read
Alright well then, nope, okay away we go then
Hello?!
Whose there?!
Aah not always
You don't read anything!
Tuump
Whatever
Apparently not, okay
Even thought I could only see myself in the mirror
To the basement we go then
Is- nevermind, that's locked
What did I just read?
And into the basement for some reason
I dunno why we'd volunteer to go down there
What about these boxes? Are these the boxes that bullied you
Or are these the boxes that bullied you?
Which one of these do I need to smash into pulp?! ..I cant move
There we go, there was a barrel in the way